sur les ondes de Fox News ce matin le
président de la Chambre des
représentants se dit confiant que
l'accord de principe sera adopté puisque
95% des élus républicains en chambre ils
sont favorables selon lui
traduction la Chambre des représentants
à majorité républicaine doit voter ce
mercredi puis ensuite ce sera au tour du
Sénat un vote très attendu mais dont le
résultat demeure incertain
à la Chambre des Représentants
s'opposent à l'entente qui survient au
terme de longue tractations
sur Twitter un élu républicain qualifie
l'entente de folie je ne voterai pas
pour mettre notre pays en faillite
écrit-il les deux côtés il y a de
l'opposition autant de côté des
républicains qui des démocrates dans les
franges les plus à gauche et à droite le
président lui défend le texte un
compromis entre les deux parties et
exhorte les deux chambres à l'adopter
selon lui l'accord de principe réduira
les dépenses tout en protégeant des
programmes publics essentiels
est avancée on dépasse on ne paie pas
les dettes des États-Unis on le sait pas
ce qui va se passer sans entente Joe
Biden craint un défaut de paiement
catastrophique les possibilités une
récession un crash boursier le texte de
la corde doit relever le plafond
d'endettement public des États-Unis
pendant deux ans soit jusqu'à
présentielle de 2024 celui-ci est
présentement fixé à 31400 milliards de
dollars ici adiacin Radio-Canada
Montréal